non non non tu aimerais ouais j'adore je
ne pourrais pas vivre dans un château maintenant je ne voudrais pas d'
une maison trop grande la
maison dans laquelle je vis est juste
assez grande c'est un peu j'en doute je me sentirais
seul dans une grande maison, je pense écrire une
chanson, je pense que je vais commencer par la
mélodie, les paroles ou la musique, puis construire à partir de
là mon plat français préféré, les mul
frites,
oh c'est belge, mais non, ouais, mais
je veux en dire plus gratuitement et tu peux juste
prétends-le croque monsieur c'est très
bien ouais travailler avec Eminem a été l'un
des moments forts de ma carrière. J'étais
très très reconnaissant de pouvoir faire ça
et c'est un gars très gentil. J'ai
collaboré avec Nick foo et j'ai fait
quelque chose avec soprano aussi et  qui
d'autre M Pokhara
je pense que Luann est incroyable je pense qu'elle est
vraiment géniale, ce serait génial de faire quelque chose
avec elle à un moment donné mais ouais il y a
beaucoup de super artistes français pour moi 2018
je vais juste faire une tournée donc je
te verrai au  La France joue aux chaussures, montre
qu'ils sont géniaux merci merci